[Music]
and too much motivation news calm it
down wait how can you have too much
motivation let's see okay
submitted by Asian persuasion that's
that's that's the name of my dick youth
hockey coach is fired after giving an
outrageous pep talk curse out the kids
or something and slap them in the face
what sport is this hockey
Oh easy come on now hockey's already
aggressive as it is huh if you don't win
this game I'm a snap this dick stick it
up your [ __ ] ass and walk around like
a human lollipop some I think there's a
aggression appropriate behavior per
sport like if you're a tennis coach you
can only be this aggressive yeah
properly sure like I'm like I think like
MMA aggression versus you know golf
aggression might be a little different I
think it should be age stage because you
can't go to a [ __ ] t-ball team and
treat them like you know they're like a
college league I've seen it though yeah
do they treat the children like it's a
Braveheart speech and they're going in
to direct it towards the kids they do
the they're a little bit like passive
aggressive they're just talking to like
the referee which is probably another
parent but then they're talking [ __ ]
about the kid to the ref like these are
[ __ ] cheater
you know the colonists [ __ ] cheated
well I thought you meant like you was
talking [ __ ] to his kid or something
like Teddy not you if you don't make
that free-throw means you don't want
dinner like or something like that
[ __ ] up I wish my parents put me at
this that's where the Asian side of
white parents come out is there in
sports oh yeah that's what do you mean
by that so you know Asian parents it's
conditional love right yeah bring home
an A I'm not talking to you you're not
my son
yeah I think like white parents they're
very accepting of that but then when
you're playing sports and they're like
Timmy
remember those free throws we've been
working on yeah they're not my [ __ ]
son you [ __ ] miss five of those oh
it's like
also even we've been mistaken why people
all along yeah they get it but it's in
baseball basketball soccer ball soccer
they get it there we get it in piano
violin yeah
karate math or something math spelling
bee for the Indian yeah um they're gonna
tell me what the [ __ ] we've got practice
in a [ __ ] well why parents grab ya and
they're screaming well they even scream
at the [ __ ] blind
hey what does that do to the kid though
I bet you the kid grows up on [ __ ] down
they go I feel like I'm Asian
yeah what about the Mexican kids they
just purchased so show up he was around
I'm not saying he's not around I'm
saying at the games they're not there
yeah they're too busy working hard man
making that [ __ ] money did you is you
that's been a no yeah el dinero man come
on now I know my Hispanic people they're
hard workers dude what's up Oh dolly yes
this story ice takes place in Colorado
and the this is the assistant coach now
you guys are gonna see I'm gonna play a
video oh yeah and he's giving this pep
talk to this team here how old are they
I was trying to find that I couldn't I
couldn't find that wheeze let them be
ain't no they don't look that young I'm
guessing maybe like 12 13 it's a youth
as I hear they shot better Judith if the
most inspirational [ __ ] ever
extra height was he
those kids are kind of big but they got
faces like the big green they're like in
junior high like a hockey gear to the
Kraken obviously Chevy's having fun with
them then laughing everyone's laughing
well he doesn't have the kids respect
that's why it's so funny that's fine
that's fine called it did yeah with the
voice like that it's hard to come but
when you start speaking it's like a
normal voice he sounds fun yeah I mean
he doesn't pump me up to like oh the
kids were laughing something yet yeah
it's kind of joke like you got fired yes
I know why poor guy who was recruiting
and one of this you know I wanted to
know that too it was one of the kids
that was recording at home I mean all
the kids were laughing he wasn't mad at
them for laughing it's not like he was
putting on an act and act innocent Act
and like what like kids at that age
don't [ __ ] curse kids were [ __ ] at
that age so who got him fired the
teachers like what happened here like it
just got too popular and too many
parents said I'm appalled so this video
was posted on a Facebook page and that's
how it ended up going viral this one
website picked it up called Deadspin
calm and that's how the rest of the
media found out about
and they were just saying how the
Littleton Hawks which is like the the
youth hockey place that's when they were
they found out about that video and then
that's when they said like you know we
want to apologize for this behavior
there's this in no way reflects the
Association does reflect the Association
yeah but they're just saying like you
know that they will no longer be
involved well it just shows that the
Association doesn't know how to have fun
so far I want an association to come out
be like [ __ ] what sport team doesn't do
with this yeah were you robbed
of a childhood I mean under my coaches
did that but we were all girls and it's
a different different but I think all
girl team is different a lot of my
coaches did death but then like not in a
comical way like it was like legit [ __ ]
though but then you felt motivated
though I think for him he went a little
bit overboard where he kind of like [ __ ]
this guy [ __ ] that yeah here the kids
weren't laughing like if my coaches sort
of cussing none of the you know I was in
the chess team they used to scream at me
too
he's also an assistant coach right he's
not like the main general
yeah but he's part of the that you know
what I think he was doing though I think
he was playing that mad TV character
that coach is
[Applause]
Oh changes voice to be coach I hope so
I'm almost a hundred percent that's
coach Hines as he was doing yeah that's
his voice that's why they're laughing
it's the characters coach I am I might
be an inside job or something right
that's that's a thousand percent that's
coach Hines that he's imitating us where
the kids are laughing if he was serious
and the kids the amount of laughter that
was in that video the kids he would have
been like what the [ __ ] are you laughing
at this is serious it was when Keegan
yeah he was trying to test his class for
steroids or something and Bobby was
sitting on a bench his character called
coach Hines and he was a Japanese
kidding Yamanashi okay yeah yeah now
definitely a coach impersonation
mouthing I think it's just that when
things like this gets out to the public
they gotta do something about it hey
dude it's a different age now
everything's you got to be careful yeah
exactly yeah they were just saying that
[ __ ] detective dude they do not
condone this type of behavior and that
that coach has been removed what's he
gonna do after that job though huh huh
well he has to go back to being a class
clown come on now or maybe has to get
hired by more aggressive sport oh yeah
dude college or college will be okay I
don't know the high school high school
hockey or college hockey mmm-hmm cuz I
know football the coaches were very mean
they said some mean stuff yeah
Oh psychological [ __ ] to to get ya to
motive physical do I did grab your face
man yeah they're more individualized so
like if you squeeze your butt really no
they just you know it's more about
psychology like getting over your fear
and they make you run a shit-ton note
like they just give you analogies like
if you were wrestling this kid in our
room you just wrestle them why why is it
any different with the when the lights
are on you know what I'm saying so like
it gets you in the right mind state oh I
know it's right yeah just so you know
just mental warfare type [ __ ]
my karate you were making too much eye
contact over here listen my self-esteem
has dropped dramatically as we started
[Laughter]
you know when you're very physically
active and maybe you're gonna be like
that with taiko and you starts being
into the supports I scream at him he's
not that type of problem cuz he's not a
screamer
like he doesn't he'd like or maybe not a
screamer but when you started me he's
not a screamer
yeah he doesn't scream like he screams
by himself but you know like wait ready
when you're T sort of hype somebody else
up he screams but like the way that
they're saying aggressively like okay
did it or that's what you're talking
about right oh yeah I guess how to like
prep them up for a game like if Pike if
Tiger as a college boy or like this like
a youth do it so I thought she was
asking in that way where I feel like
it's kind of dumb I don't feel like
you're gonna be like that I guess I
understand quite are you talking about
like you're telling in that exact way
yeah or just aggressive yelling nature
I'm just asking like once Tigers and
sports and you're trying to prep them up
for a game like how would you go about
it you just told me something to be more
calm I think I'll go it's not a
situation of puffier probably like if
it's like if he's going for his white
belt test improbable let's go you got
this whatever you know what I think he's
like an aggressive sport I guess like
hockey like you gotta do the opposite
like would you own this film
cuz it's so aggressive like MMA you
gotta like pet him on the back of his
head
alright you just got two more rounds to
go buddy
nobody says some twisted [ __ ] he's a
cute mom's dangling
oh [ __ ] could be me your mom's dangling
off a cliff [ __ ] are you gonna do it nah
that's too soft dude your mom is getting
raped in the mouth oh yeah yeah it's
gonna be something like that yeah I mean
I like aggressive stuff so I probably
would but I wouldn't take it like too
far or anything like that it's situation
appropriate like if he's in the house
before the game he's not gonna come up
let's go come in the bleachers the
different story
yeah
[Music]
you